well brian may is mental health
awareness month and today is mental
health
action day and really a good reminder to
say that sometimes it's okay not to be
okay
that's according to hope means nevada
who is constantly working to eliminate
youth suicide
christian casada spoke to a las vegas
family who was sharing their
heartbreaking story in hopes that it
might prevent others pain
that's right denise well i spoke to
christina colony about her late sister
aaliyah she was 17 years old when she
took her life
according to family prior to aliyah's
death in 2017
she did not appear to show any type of
signs that she was struggling
christina tells me her sister's death
was definitely an eye-opener
for her and her entire family about
mental health they now want to spread
awareness through her story
colony knows nothing will bring her
sister back but hopes
to be a shoulder to lean on after a
tough year brought on by the pandemic
i think she was just in a manic state
and that's something i've learned after
the fact i
did not know as much about mental health
as i do now
and i'm not claiming that i'm a
professional by any sorts but
what i do know is that no one should be
embarrassed to ask for help or feel like
they're not worth it because
they are so worth it well christina will
be sharing her story tonight during a
fundraising event at ferraro's italian
restaurant on paradise and harmon
the business owner will be making a
generous donation to hope means nevada
a community-based non-profit that
focuses on youth
suicide now according to hope means
nevada two
out of every three teens with depression
don't get treatment and suicide
is the number two killer among teens
christian gossip is 8 news now